rund um den boxer südlich von leipzig
wurde in den vergangenen jahren ein
richtig schöner weg gebaut aber der zehn
kilometer lange radweg rund um den see
soll jetzt kein radweg mehr sein der
grund verschiedene staatliche stellen
können sich nicht einigen wer für den
weg verantwortlich ist absurde
konsequenz gerade erst aufgestellte
radwege schilder müssen wieder weg kann
man nicht verstehen ich habe ein kleines
kind hinten drin ich muss möglichst
schnell zum ziel ohne groß umweg
anhalten sondern ich bin auf die
schilder angewiesen ist so besonders ist
totaler quatsch als ausrichter braucht
muss die schilder hier um sich
zurechtzufinden der boxer sie ist ein
geflutete ehemaliger braunkohletagebau
die renaturierung wurde vom staatlichen
bergbausanierer der lmbv umgesetzt der
see besteht aus einem großen
naturschutzgebiet außerdem wurde ein
wunderschöner panoramaweg geschaffen die
kommunen haben die strecke nun als
radweg ausgeschildert doch jetzt gibt es
streit die lmbv fordert die anlieger
städte kitzscher bonn und freiburg auf
den radweg zu übernehmen das lehnen die
städte aber kategorisch ab der weg sei
teilweise in einem zu schlechten zustand
die folge die neuen schilder kommen
wieder weg obwohl der weg seit jahren
für touristen als haupt radroute in den
landkarten steht
weiß darauf vor ort jetzt vertreibt sich
kommt einfach nicht so denn jetzt hin
ich finde es skandalös eigentlich dann
wir sind ja gerade angekommen und also
wenn wir keine wegweiser hätten wir
würden wir im dschungel wie in der
wildnis hier um ihren für die in dem bv
ist der fall klar sie will die
verantwortung für den radweg nicht
übernehmen durch die lmbv wurden und
werden wege errichtet die ausschließlich
als wirtschaftswege zur bewirtschaftung
der flächen und gewässer und allein dem
zweck der befahrbarkeit durch die lmbv
dienen aber auch in den rathäusern
bleibt man stur die
verkehrssicherungspflicht für den weg
will ihn niemand übernehmen wir sind
selber unglücklich über den fall und
hoffen dass wir schnellst mögliche
lösung finden weil das gebiet ist
dornröschen schlaf aber wenn niemand die
verantwortung übernimmt
der dornröschenschlaf noch länger dauern
es kann keiner nachvollziehen weil die
schilder stirn kein
nicht nachvollziehbar die behörden
untereinander dies betrifft müssen
einfach hand in hand arbeiten und warum
ist das nicht zu schade rund um den
boxer sie wurde mit viel steuergeld ein
schöner radweg gebaut der wird jetzt
aber nicht mehr ausgewiesen weil sich
niemand darum kümmern will das nennt man
wohl typisch deutschen bürokratismus